all right well I guess they know that we
drive up that way whether our multiple
IEDs ambush is often not far behind so
this could be an all-night are we gonna
have enough time oh yeah we've got
next comes news we all dreaded to hear
indicating that they have an ambush
ahead of us at this time we'd like to
know what is available at right now mind
the air see if I can set up an immediate
over here Jose the team's air support
specialist sense a distress call to all
NATO aircraft nearby and relays the
teams exact position
five hero seven zero they say that
they're set up for us right now in an
ambush down there in the village and
possibly up here in the in the ridges
we've been blocked on the cliffside for
over two hours now it's a dangerous and
nearly indefensible position you as the
camera crew yeah well you got to keep
filming of course but if things get bad
I'd hide toward the back of the truck
three-hour delay seven IEDs blown word
finally comes down that the ridge top is
clear
Robb's command vehicle carrying two
national geographic channel filmmakers
is the first to head up the hill
we turn onto a demine path marked with
green chem lights
once atop the hill we get out to film
the next Americans coming up
the night is so dark and even our night
vision lens has trouble seeing
suddenly truck number three is
illuminated by the headlights of the
Afghan army pickup behind it
bad move by the Afghans revealing our
position for miles around
as truck number three comes up the lane
we film it moving towards us about 30
feet away